the flexibility of kubeflow lets you run
your ml jobs
anywhere you can run kubernetes and
gives you an entire platform to work
with
sometimes you don't need the entire qflo
platform
but you still want to use pipelines to
orchestrate machine learning workflows
let's look at cloud ai platform
pipelines a google cloud service that
lets you focus
even more on your ml and less on your
infrastructure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you want to read more about how to
run pipelines on google cloud check out
the documentation link below
previously i talked about how to work
with pipelines as part of a kubeflow
deployment
but we can use cloud ai platform
pipelines to get the same user interface
and back-end functionality
if you don't need the rest of qflo and
are just looking for the ability to work
with pipelines
cloud ai platform gives you a quick way
to set up an installation
on top of that authentication with other
google cloud services is built in
this lets you focus on building your
pipeline and integrating with other
cloud services
without needing to manage a complex
deployment
let's start by getting a pipelines
installation set up
to try it out head to the google cloud
console and use the left navigation to
find
pipelines under ai platform then click
the new instance button google cloud
will set up a kubernetes cluster and
then deploy the pipeline installation on
top of it
but all the details are handled for you
once it's set up and running
you'll have the full pipelines ui and
sdk to start working with
we'll go back to the pipelines page and
click open pipelines dashboard
to get to the same user interface we can
see experiments and runs here
as well as look at our metadata and
artifacts don't forget to check out the
previous metadata management episode
which goes into more detail about it so
it's still possible to upload a compiled
pipeline through the same user interface
but what if you're using a notebook for
your model here's where we can use
another service to help us out
cloud ai platform notebooks in our
previous videos we've talked about the
advantages of running a notebook in the
cloud
rather than on your local machine cloud
ai platform notebooks gives you a simple
way to do just that
you can create a new notebook quickly
and jump into a jupyter lab interface
back in the google cloud console just
click new instance
and choose an environment since we're
working with a tensorflow one example
we'll choose tensorflow 1.15 without any
gpus
and hit create once again all of the
infrastructure is taken care of behind
the scenes
and we're able to just click open
jupyter lab to get to our interface
where we can create notebooks and
execute them since we're using the same
notebook from the last video
we've already cloned the same repository
here
code for pipelines is made to be
reusable so we don't need to change
anything to create an execution we will
need to specify
the same properties our google cloud
project and the cloud storage bucket
where our model will be stored
there's one more change we need to make
we have to tell the pipeline's sdk where
our pipeline's endpoint is located
this is as easy as copying the url of
our hosted pipeline
which we can get by clicking settings
next to a pipeline
and storing it as a variable in our
notebook since the same user created
both the notebook and the pipeline's
installation
the authentication is taken care of for
us we'll then modify the line where we
execute the pipeline
and point it to the server and then run
the notebook
other than that this is the same
pipeline so we'll still be using the
cloud ai platform to do the training and
serving of the model
we're just doing it from a different
environment cloud ai platforms can be an
easy way to get a pipeline's environment
without having to set up an entire
keyflow deployment
in addition it's easy to integrate with
other google cloud services
to help extend your ml projects like
hosted notebooks
model training and serving try it out
for yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
you